all right hot breath averse welcome back
to comedians on skype talking comedy
today's guest is one of my very favorite
comedians not only for her overall
attitude but her brutal honesty and
transparency on stage and we're gonna
learn all about that and much more by
answering your questions if you're
watching this on youtube if you want to
get involved in these q and a's in the
future go into the description and click
the link to join our Facebook group
that's where we do all the interactive
questions but in the meantime in between
time it is time to welcome to the show
the hilarious rosebuds Baker everyone
welcome rosebuds to the show thank you
thank you so much this is where applause
would happen if we had audiences anymore
I guess I actually I have sound effects
but I don't think you can hear them via
Skype but the people watching can hear
the sound effects so oh nice
great beautiful yeah this is my big
break I mean this this Q&A show is gonna
be my big break I've been doing comedy
ten years but it's gonna be a Skype show
that takes me to the next level I love
it
so first off we're gonna jump into
listener questions but I actually had a
few just to start off with and one
because a common question we've actually
gotten are especially from newer comics
is like should I use my real name or a
stage name and I know you specifically
with rosebuds is your real names
rosemary but you go by rosebud on stage
what what made you decide to do a stage
name and would you recommend it for a
comedian I didn't actually I didn't
decide on a stage name I've just been
called rosebud since I was a kid okay
so I never went by rosemary so in a way
it's like a stage name but it's also
just like my name as far as it's what
I've been called so um I didn't you know
the short answer is I I didn't yeah that
was it I was just like that's what I
call
I'll just call myself that and uh yeah
cuz rosemary feels like someone in a
wheelchair I don't know why it just I
can picture myself old you know
wheelchair and then I might change it to
Rosemary okay perfect I was trying to
start off we'd be like hey I did a
little research and you're like actually
I've been called rosebud my whole life
it's not really that well it's kind of a
tricky it's a tricky thing because it's
like convoluted you know it's not that
like cut and dried fact but I was like I
was impressed that you knew it was
rosemary because that's uh I mean that's
hidden pretty much not that I tried to
but I just don't have it anywhere other
than government documents so that's what
we do here yeah I go I like I'm like a
private investigator I research guests
and like my favorite is when people are
like yo who have you been talking to
they're like kind of nerd war but of
like comedy so right yeah another
popular question we get is in terms of
like going full-time into comedy and you
started in New York and you started as
an actor and then you kind of went into
comedy just because a friend recommended
that would be the only thing you're good
at
so it's like so right whatwhat was that
early
well one jumping into comedy New York
that's pretty much is jumping into the
Lions Den but what were those early
years like out on the grind and how have
you been able to cause you only do
comedy like six seven years is that
right yeah yeah six years so like how
what is that early grind but then also
six years I mean you've you've almost
become almost like the face of Comedy
Central in a lot of ways you're all over
their content so how were you able to
excel so quickly from like that early
grind I you know it's funny cuz
everybody says that it's been so fast
and it doesn't feel like that it feels
like I've been doing it for like it just
feels like I've been doing it forever
but I think that's just because of how
exhausted I am and so
you've done all this research so you
probably know that I'm an addict and I I
think I just put all of that addict
energy into working and you know the
first couple years I remember I was
barking on MacDougal Street as you do
and it was like I remember it was like
when the polar vortex hit and none of us
had known what the [__] that was we'd
never even heard of that
we were like what is a polar vortex and
then it it came and we were like holy
[__] like it was so cold that my bones
hurt you know like it felt like my bones
were made of metal and it was that kind
of cold and I remember just sitting out
there like I was so happy like I had no
idea how unhappy I should have been I I
didn't know like how terrible my life
really was but I because I just loved it
like I really loved doing comedy I loved
being around the people I loved the
community of it and and I really I I
really loved the figuring out the craft
of comedy like I knew that if someone is
an actor you know it looks like anybody
could do it but the truth is there's
like there's a technique to acting and I
was like I know there's a technique to
comedy but nobody will tell me what it
is
and I and the one thing that I'm really
that I wear my blind spot is is in
writing I don't know what a what a real
joke is we're like how to tell a real
joke
so I would watch these specials and I
would like play the premise write that
down pause it you know then play the
punchline and write that down and I did
this for like three or four specials I
mean I did it with Rodney Dangerfield I
did it with Schumer I did it with a tell
every comic that I could think of that
has like really strong joke structure
and don't open that door the dogs are
gonna flip the
[__] out and so I I basically just like
went for it and didn't stop and you know
and Here I am and I feel like I I won't
stop until it stops being fun you know
and if it stops being fun then I know
I'm first thing I'll do is I'm like I'll
probably look at myself and be like what
am I doing wrong that this is no longer
fun for me and then if I'm not doing
anything wrong then it might just not be
for me anymore but that's sort of the
that's my attitude about it as I just
try to as long as I'm enthusiastic about
it I'll keep doing it you know yeah and
to keep to keep like climbing the ladder
was it just you're out on stage you know
like four times a night and things like
that is it just being around and then
like a Booker saw you hear that then
took you on this showcase that maybe
Comedy Central or an agent saw you like
what was kind of the progression from
like you in the polar vortex at open
mikes grinding it out to then starting
to get that next level of exposure well
it was pretty much that it was pretty
much just barking and try and get myself
booked for at least four she's eating
some [__] on a plant um they were just
trying to get myself booked for like
four or five years you know what I mean
and then were four years and no nobody
recognized what I was doing as funny and
no one really gave a [__] I mean you
know people were like oh she's funny but
I was happening and then I got my first
Montreal audition four years in which i
think is kind of late for some people
like for people that are genuinely like
nobody knows about I think four years
kind of undercover helped me because
when I did do that when I did do the
Montreal audition that was the year that
they were shooting inside jokes and I
did
a an interview afterwards everyone who
was auditioning was interviewing outside
you know like introducing themselves and
saying like yeah this is my first time
but blah kind of saying what their
experience was at the festival and three
weeks later I got a call that they
wanted to come and shoot with me for
like two three days to take back to the
network and see if the network wanted to
use me and I was like this is weird I
don't know I don't know how real this is
but sure uh-huh and then I ended up
looking at and when inside jokes started
shooting and I actually got into the
festival that was when things started to
like move you know and I mean that was
when things kind of started to I got a
little bit of momentum I had worked with
you know when when I got back from
Montreal I had got a new manager he was
getting me out inside jokes dropped I
start I got this like the ringers with
Bill burr yeah and then that was in
April so you all kind of just like all
of that [__] like happened almost on its
own accord like not to say that I wasn't
trying to make it happen but that wasn't
necessarily like the goal I mean it was
but I wasn't I wasn't just sewing for
that like I really wanted to just be as
funny as I could be and as authentic as
I could be and I feel like I really
tried to make that my number one focus
so like I think you know at least if I
if I was rejected by the industry I
would have been rejected on my own terms
they would have been like hey it's not
your jokes it's you yeah and I would
have been like okay well I can't help
that
so [__] it I tried yeah like that's so
valuable to to like focus on just being
funny and authentic as possible a lot of
comics are what's gonna get me here
there but it's really no just just focus
on being funny and uniquely you and let
all your opportunities come from that
yeah yeah I mean a lot of times you
think about what has happened to you and
the stories in your life and you're like
wow there's nothing really there that's
not really funny but the truth is like
it it's all there everything's there
it's all about like what have you been
through and why do you see things the
way that you see them and it doesn't
have to be the only you know you're not
going to be the first person who's ever
thought of anything you're not going to
reinvent the wheel but you can be
authentic and that alone will make you
unique what was it it must have been
your authenticity that attracted bill
burr to you because you did his show and
then now you have a podcast on his
network as well like what what was that
experience like getting to work with
Bill burr and you guys connecting um it
was the same I he's like he's one of
those comics that I have watched since
before I ever even thought about being a
comic and so I am truly like I I get
just stupid around him you know like I
can't even speak like the way I normally
speak I just kind of like I just try to
say nothing because I know that whatever
is gonna come out of my mouth is gonna
try to impress him and if I know him
he's gonna feel that and it's gonna be
gross so I just go catatonic around him
I just go completely silent I was like
you know what I'll just show up I'll do
my set I will not I will not try to lick
his [__] in any way and I'll just be
I'll just say thank you for having me
and leave it at that because I was like
anything else I do is gonna be gross
because I worship the dude you know and
nobody wants that kind of responsibility
nobody wants to know that they're being
worshipped it's gross you know so which
your happiness when you actually saw him
in heaven then what did you like what
did you do what was that like I was just
like hey it's so nice to meet you no
thanks for having me and then he asked
me questions about my life and I
answered them and I tried to just if I
said something funny then great and if
not then I didn't care I just wanted to
come off as like a real person and that
is what it was like I just it was also
very like it was a shoot day so it was
just like we're just gonna shoot yeah
you know and so we were at work and that
that is a that's great for comics cuz
it's like okay we're here for a bigger
thing we're here to do a job we'll do
the job and then we'll all go home you
know and if we connect with one another
great eye for is like really one of
those people that I'm just like I when
people ask you you know like who
molded your comedy and who like he's
such a good example of someone who who
he is onstage is so so close to who he
is in person and that's what I want I
want it to be that you know it's like a
slight exaggeration of who I really am
so and he's just such a perfect example
of that and he's so funny
and if you write his jokes down they
don't really sound like I mean there's
jokes in there there's punchlines all
over the place but he makes it look like
he's just talking and that's such a good
example of a like a comic you know
rather than someone who just knows how
to tell jokes
yeah and that that's what I admire about
you is just like your your material and
the things you talk about and that you
can find humor and all this darkness and
it comes off as real and authentic and
not like oh she's trying to be edgy you
know what I mean
but it is like she's literally just
talking about her life and her
experiences and to kind of parlay this
into the first question here from skip
on gel from he's out in Louisiana
but he asked that do you have a writing
discipline or exercise that you use
often and like do you is yeah is there
like a structure you put this dark
material through to find the funny on
the other side of it um well my stuff I
think with my stuff I have to it's so
personal that I have to do it one-on-one
with people like I write down what it is
that I think is funny and maybe it's
like a portion of a joke like maybe
there's something that I just find funny
like okay here's an example like I this
is not gonna end this is not going to
sound funny but like I was thinking
about how you know I talk about my
sister's death in in my jokes and like
right now that's kind of what I'm
talking about on stage or used to be and
I one of the things that kind of has
stuck with me for years is I remember
being at the wake and everybody talking
about how beautiful she looked and I
remember being like uh she looks
disgusting
like she's dead I mean I don't know what
you're talking about like that and that
remember I remembered that being
something that it's funny to me because
it's so like it's just one of those
things we do as human beings where we're
looking at a dead body they look if
you've ever seen a dead body they look
like they were like like a rough-draft
at a wax museum like they just looked
[__] up and like someone left it in
the heat you know and and I remember all
my family being like she looks so
beautiful and me being like what um and
so I was trying to write that and so
I'll talk to certain people that I know
and be like is this funny to you
and they'll be like yeah that's funny
maybe if you're gonna go you either need
to go harder on it or you need to maybe
dump maybe water it down like a little
bit
it and I you know I don't know how I do
that but I just it ends up happening
like if I have an idea in my head of
what is funny and I know I'll end up
writing a joke about it especially if it
won't go away
so is it like an exercise the same way
that you would you know do inventory at
your business no but it's like it's an
exercising kind of staying connected to
what I think is funny and writing it as
many different ways as possible to see
what comes out and what sticks you know
so it's like this is funny to me let me
bounce it off other people that I
respect there since if you don't you
plug that in so that I can use the other
one because these are dying my computer
is it's [__] and it doesn't have
volume so that's quite earpods die then
we're then the interview is over I'm
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt you
know you're told no you're totally fine
Andy's a good word there yeah he is he's
a good sport he I'm surprised we haven't
killed each other I am sure in 40 days
together yeah how long have you been
hanging before you like jumped into
quarantine together we were dating for
five months okay he's still still a lots
of learning about each other yeah what
is the living situation guys we got
engaged three days into quarantine so
where we were like how did he propose or
did you propose you know he proposed but
we were watching Eternal Sunshine we
were watching a movie and then eating he
went to Little Dom's and got Italian
food and then told me that there was a
ring in the sauce for the tiramisu and I
was like that's not a thing you don't
put sauce on tiramisu so I was not
surprised
I'm not I'm like the worst person to be
I'm just the worst I cuz I can't pretend
to do something that isn't like I'm not
gonna pretend to be surprised about
something right if it's not surprising
me uh-huh
which doesn't mean I'm not excited about
it I was super excited I was like I
really feel like Andy and I are perfect
for each other I've never been able to
be so much myself with anybody in my
life
but I
he was like reser prized and I was like
no why would I be surprised did you cry
were you like yes of course
or were you like tara misu really no it
wasn't that it was he said I wasn't he
said I didn't seem excited and I think
that's just what happens when I get
excited I think I just like I think I
just try to like put a lid on it which
is something I'm working on in therapy
uh because I don't express my emotions
fully I like I go like I shut down so I
was just like yes and then that's it
yeah okay so romantic
so yeah I might as well have [__]
given him a handshake and asked him to
sign paperwork like I was it was I did
it like a business deal Oh anyway I wish
I had that's so beautiful what what a
beautiful proposal it's in the desert
you have extra desert yeah well
congratulations congratulations yeah
I've been married all over three years
now it's amazing so yeah well yeah when
you say amazing that feels like you're
leaving a lot out but okay no I I work I
really do like I mean yeah I really do
like being married I mean it takes away
that whole like when you're dating or
pursuing it's like it's a lot of work
and it requires a lot of thought and
like what ifs but now it's like you're
married and you're like well I mean
whatever where are we gonna go at this I
mean you know there's always a divorce
of course but my parents have proven
that a couple times but
foot buddy like yeah it likes you focus
on what's more important than like oh
how many swipe rights did I get today
you know so it's yeah it opens up a new
world like it like having a dog but you
guys have to yeah out of the game yeah
we were both addicts in recovery so we
have impulse control issues and all of
those have come out in the quarantine we
have adopted a puppy who's died Andy's
hair I'm cutting my bangs
I joined tik-tok um we got engaged it's
I've done everything that you can
possibly do in quarantine I mean other
than get pregnant I feel like I've done
every single thing that people are like
hey maybe hold off on that there's still
time there's still time right so let's
yeah let's let's jump back into these
questions here and let's see oh yeah we
have a lot yeah people
people are really excited when they were
seeing you were coming on here because
there's not much there's a lot of
content you have something yeah Oh her
sound died so we're gonna take a moment
for rosebud sound but thanks for tuning
in everyone can you hear me I can't hear
you yes hold on yeah no problem
hello hello
are you there it's alright one second
it doesn't work it doesn't work with
those you can't hear me
one second yeah no problem second
goddamnit I use yours
not beautiful can I use yours
sure oh that's love sorry jeez he's
sharing his air buds buds right there
sorry no you're great
cuz I can hear you but you can't hear me
sounds like yeah I do love how angry
she's getting though cuz that's my
favorite part about her humor that's how
oh okay hi oh you can hear hurry okay
cool I was talking to the group I was
like I love how angry you're getting
that's my favorite part about your humor
is how you can just you're so cutting
with it it's like I can't and you can't
get your goddamn computer fixed cuz of
course they're like oh this isn't a
[__] essential business and it's like
how is it not essential it's the only
way we can [__] talk to people right
now it's like jeez I know we don't have
you asks but can I get a computer please
yeah that's all I want
I just everyone in America to get a new
laptop anyway I'm sorry about that
no worries at all thanks for kudos ugh
I'm gonna do an applause for Andy for
sharing his earbuds with you that's so
generous that's love right there did you
hear me that whole time I could hear you
but I guess you couldn't hear me but
okay I could hear you though but you are
weird yeah you weren't responding so I
was assuming my voice wasn't going
through okay
um yeah sorry anyway what was the
question you were gonna give me another
question we were about to jump start um
start
hammering out the the viewer questions
here so let me see let's do this is a
good one let's do its do karlie sherek
she was super jazzed about this she said
would love to know how you see comedy
evolving and adapting to social
distancing guidelines that may last for
a significant chunk of time also best
pizza and NYC okay best pizza in NYC I
have a real soft spot for Fiore's next
to the grizzly pear which is where I
would feed myself when I was um coming
up that's I love they've got these like
tiny little pepperonis and they're
they're awesome I love Furies let's see
and then in terms of how comedies like
adapting to this [__] I think here's
what I think is the boom you took a real
hit like for sure we are we were in the
middle of a comedy boom that just got
this isn't gonna be uplifting I just
need to preface it with that but I think
we what is going to happen is the people
that we're doing arenas and you know
theaters are gonna go back to doing
clubs and doing the road and I think you
know because it's like even theaters is
too many people in one place so the
people that were just starting to
headline like myself and the people that
are working towards headlining we're all
gonna get I think bumped down that's
what I think is gonna happen I don't
know but that's kind of like logically
where I see things going because it's
you know they're not gonna give somebody
like they'll give me maybe headlining
dates like go on a week I'm hoping but
there or on a weekend but they're not
going to give
me like a whole weekend if they can get
Bert Kreischer in there you know because
he's just absolutely gonna sell it out
and people will pay more so each ticket
will be worth more and they can keep the
social distancing by up selling tickets
that's what I'm seeing is gonna happen I
also think a lot of clubs are not going
to be able to survive this and I hope
that they can yeah but I I don't see
that happening because you know how much
were they making to begin with it's
already like it's like a I don't know I
think I think we're a little bit [__]
but I on the bright side I think the
people who are really meant to be doing
comedy and the people who are really
really loved it will stick around and I
think people that were in this as kind
of like that saw it as a way to get into
the business because comedy is like a
Ponzi scheme you know what I mean it's
like so you can climb quickly you have
access to people and connections with
people that you wouldn't necessarily
have because comedians are so accessible
so I think there's people that saw that
and that were involved in it that didn't
belong here you know and to those people
I'm I'm so happy to say [__] off - yeah
yeah somebody'll thin the herd this will
thin the herd in a good way yeah yes I
agree yeah yeah awesome and this was
actually the first question and I I
scrolled past it but skip had also asked
what did you do for your SNL audition
and do you have any bizarre stories of
the experience I didn't have enough an
SNL audition I had a showcase for SNL
and I did my standup but the whole time
I was like why am I here
because I didn't know what they I was
just like
there with like Larry Owens and a bunch
of people that were good characters and
stuff like that and I was sitting there
the whole time just being like ok cool
I'm I'm so happy to be here I think they
were looking at me on a writing mhmmm
for for writing but I don't know there
was very little about that audition that
I was told
mainly because at the time I I had reps
that didn't didn't do a great job of
communicating with me what was happening
so they were just like SNL wants to see
your standup and did you go in and do
like the standard you show up at the
studio stage and you're just doing
stand-up in front of like three people
type deal no I did I did it at UCB so
that they have showcases that's where
they about distance and they just kind
of like look you and they see what you
do and they get to know you and I had
just gotten back from Montreal and so I
just did what I did at Montreal I did my
stand-up yeah very nice I wish had more
their wish there was a more interesting
thing there but it was just the same as
any other show yeah that's what yeah I
didn't realize you had audition for SNL
but that um but then he asked that so I
was like oh he must have known something
but yeah more of those showcases because
they'll do jfl showcases as well where
it's kind of like a comedy club jfl
night or whatever and then they may not
pick any one type deal it's kind of more
like a stand-up show yeah so this is um
about jfl and there's a lot of questions
about inside jokes which is where I
first found you and after episode one of
that I was like immediately
rosebud fan like instantly and I've been
a fan since then so there's actually a
lot of inside jokes questions which did
you get a lot of like new fans and new
like followers from that show cuz it was
very is very good show um I got uh I got
some yeah like I still get messages from
people being like I just saw it
loved it you're so funny blah blah blah
and it's really nice to hear that
because you know when that was all
filming during the middle of like the me
to stuff and the woman who the executive
at Amazon got fired because of something
involved involving that and I guess a
woman had harassed someone anyway she
was fired and so the new the new
executive promoted I mean it was like
there were some posters around the city
but that was it and I I was like well
this sucks because no one's going to see
it but because it's up there people find
it and that's the beauty of a streaming
platform is like people keep they
continue to find it and to look at it
and they see what you've done and where
you've gone since then and and it's
great for that like it's and I feel like
that's um that was a show that I could
really be proud of because when I
watched it I was like oh yeah that's
that's me I don't feel like I didn't I
didn't feel like I was painted in any
way that was different than Who I am and
I yeah I guess the short answer is yeah
that people people like the show you
know so that's great
it's be happy I'm react how much jfl
changed her career both the festival and
the TV show like how did that change a
career I would say the show changed my
you know I don't know like I wonder
sometimes would any of this have
happened without inside jokes and I
honestly think that it was just like a
perfect kind of combination cuz JSL on
its own like it can change your career
but you have to have you have to go
there not to [__] around like you have
to go there with this idea and this was
something that occurred to me while I
was there I was like oh [__] like I've
just thought about getting here I never
thought about what would happen after
this and so the whole time I was there
I was kind of having it's like panic
attack / realization that I had no goals
past jfl so I was like I need to get
really serious about what could happen
after this and like steer mike her steer
my career in a way that I wanted to go
and I met my manager there and I had a
meeting with him and I was like this is
what I want I want to be one of the most
well respected comics I was like I I
don't want to be seen as a female comic
I don't want to be seen as like I just
want my voice to be unique enough where
people stop looking at it as just female
and I and I want to be respected in
comedy the way that men are you know and
and I was and the thing about it is like
as a woman to do that I feel like we
have to try and I'm not saying it's like
we have to try harder because I think
everyone is trying really [__] hard
anyone involved in comedy is trying
really [__] hard but I think with
women specifically we have to we have to
have a very strong idea of exactly what
we want to be seen as so that we don't
get painted in a way that's like oh this
is like a niche comic like she is she
speaks mostly to this group of people I
love it when like I'll go on I was like
checking the reviews on the podcast
which is like my current obsession I
just like check reviews on that [__]
thing mm-hm but I saw this one where
this guy was like I am a tired old man
and I love listening to rosebud and I
was like that makes me so happy because
I I want to be relatable to tired old
men and I want to be relatable to
millennial women and I want to be
relatable to Gen Y and I want to be I
want it to be universal enough
um that people can relate to me even if
they don't like me but they'll like
relate and I think that's where the
authenticity yeah I think it totally a
hundred percent makes sense because that
was that's my goal with my comedy as
well and starting in Atlanta I would do
shows where I would be like the only
white guy in the zip code and then I
would go and do like a hipster bar where
I'm the only guy not wearing a beard and
flannel shirt and I wanted to make sure
that my jokes worked in like all of
those rooms and what I found and I think
that's why yours is translating so well
is that authenticity that that's what
really breaks whatever social-economic
gender differences is if you're
authentic I feel like are just
biological senses will automatically
gravitate towards authenticity yeah I
mean people can feel when you're lying
yes exactly they can feel when you're
lying to yourself so like if you're in
that stage of comedy where you're like
maybe I'll be this kind of comic right
or maybe I'll be that pine a comic don't
worry about any of that I would say what
write about something that you really
[__] know about and see where it goes
from there you know boom and this ties
in to writing this next question from
Sasha Sasha asks what some of the best
advice you've received that has helped
you improve your joke writing oh don't
try to be right try to be funny
mm-hmm that was that's the best advice
I've ever gotten was just don't because
you know you get into that trap where
you're trying to prove a point
and you're not it's not funny you know
and a lot of my comedy is trying to
prove a point but the funny has to be
there first and if you end up losing the
point to get to the joke or if the point
is ridiculous and the joke is stronger
um it's it doesn't matter you know I
mean like your
up there to preach you're not up there
as like to be the person that people
look up to you are a clown and just be
funny like even if you're a smart clown
be a smart clown like you've got to be a
clown first just be a clown who's kind
of smart yes you know funny it has to be
funny that like at the at the end of the
day whatever it is you want to be like
first off yeah it has to be funny you
can be ironic and cool or whatever but
is it funny like that's that's that's
the equalizer on everything and we've
some have gotten away from that and it's
like comics think they can just deliver
their way into attracting an audience
but it's like is it is it funny just is
it fun yeah you know you're Europe's
absurd reference that for people got you
know is it is it going to be funny in
front of people that actually like
matter you know yeah like there's a this
is the trend it's a trap that I fall
into all the time like with that premise
that I was telling you about with my
with like seeing a dead body it's like
dead bodies are ugly you know they're
not good-looking what we call them
good-looking so like like we'll be like
oh she looks so peaceful or whatever and
it's like you know I know that I'm right
about this but what's funny about that
and I'm trying to like figure that out
so it's like it's like a verbal puzzle
you know and if it doesn't end with
making you laugh it's not going to work
onstage like that's it you know
boom and this this next question
actually jumps in to the other side of
the performance equation so we're
talking about writing but samar pan or
Samar pan I'm sorry this is actually
their first time tuning in to a Q&A so
welcome to the hot breath averse but
they asked when did you realize that you
found
your voice um I think uh I don't know
it's so like it's one of those things
that I think I still am trying to figure
out I think there's a lot that I still
have to do I wouldn't say that I've
completely found my voice as a comic I
know I've found like where my interests
lie I know what I know that I'm able to
pretty much be myself but I also feel
like if you're a real person that
answering a question as if you've
already figured it out is stupid because
you're constantly figuring out who you
are and your voice is gonna change and
as long as you can keep up with you know
what what is ringing true for you that's
how you know you're still in your voice
you're still like expressing things from
your voice from your perspective and
people talk about it like it's this
thing out there that you'll like find
some day and it's it's not it's just who
you are it's like when you're in the car
with your best friend and you say
something that's hilarious
to both of you and you don't even know
why it's funny that that's like your
voice you hear it in these little
moments and then it creeps it's it finds
its way into your comedy you know like
sometimes I'll listen to my own comedy
and I'm like guys I'm so [__] angry
and it sound so like I saw so butch you
know and it's like I feel shame about it
like I feel shame when I listen to
myself
but that's if you don't feel a little
bit of embarrassment you're not risking
anything so that I think is like a good
indicator you know is if you getting
offstage and you're like ah do they just
like know too much you know I love that
if you don't feel any embarrassment then
you aren't risking anything
kind of like if yeah if you're not yeah
it's almost like if you're not bombing
you're not trying in a sense like you're
not pushing yourself out of your comfort
zone yeah I love a comic who's willing
to eat [__] I love me too and I'm really
asked what is your biggest most
embarrassing bomb what is what is
Rosebud's one that you just will never
forget um god I I'll never forget this
time and it's so funny because it's such
an inconsequential bomb in terms of like
the the broad like the overarching thing
of my career like it doesn't matter it
was a lol comedy club which is not a
club it's like a scam operation in Times
Square that's where you start I went up
yeah and I I went up and I just bombed
so bad like I forgot how to do crowd
work
like I I never bombed in a way where my
brain just like stopped working you know
where you get like bomb brain and you
just pay me like any birthday in the
anniversaries and you're like what the
whole audience is looking at you like
what the [__] did you just say and I
remember I just like left my body
I was like because I walked into a
bathroom stall and I just had to wait
until I stopped sweating that was what
happened I mean I I really just sat
there and just sweated and tried to
figure out what had just happened and
what had I done to deserve that so yeah
what went wrong why do you think you
bombed so hard I think I was unprepared
for what was about to happen like I I
think I was sitting on the side of the
stage I was like okay I'd built it up in
my head in a way that was like this is
the most important thing if I [__] this
up everything's over all of that like
you
start telling yourself these stories and
then there's too much on the line and
you go okay well there's no way that I
could perform with any kind of
relaxation or any kind of ease if I'm
making this into such a life-or-death
situation you know and so you kind of
have to realize if you're dining onstage
it doesn't you're not really dying like
you're gonna be fine you just you gotta
adjust whatever it is that you have to
adjust and for me that set taught me
know set is gonna kill me like I think I
just needed to bomb like that you know
yeah I needed to bomb in a way that made
me yeah I was just in my head exactly do
you have a pre-show ritual now because
it seemed like you were almost doomed to
bomb just by how you were setting
yourself up before you even got on stage
do you have like a pre-show ritual now
that helps you get into that mindset
know if anything I try to make I try to
make every show as low pressure as
possible hmm I try to just like do what
I would do on any other day like if
somebody calls and I have an important
date or an important show that night I
always pick up just because I'm like I
would pick up on a regular day you know
yeah I need to like lower the the status
of this show in order to do well so I
act in a way that is like that's just a
job it's just like I'm going to go and
at this point I've had so many [__]
nerve wracking and I'm lucky to have had
them but nerve-wracking opportunities
where I just thought if that bomb hadn't
happened I wouldn't know how to how to
act in a way that made these things
possible you know like we auditioning at
the cellar and then auditioning at the
cellar a second time and then you know
auditioning for Montreal on-camera
knowing that if people saw me bomb they
could go back and rewind and watch again
you know like that kind of [__] that
pressure of filming inside joke helped
me in such a huge way like I've done so
many TV tapings now I've done so many
sets for TV and I did them all in like a
four month period and a lot of them were
bad like I bombed several times on that
um on that show and I just had to be
like well bombs happen I really had to
do that so and it relaxed me to the
point where in the middle of the ringers
I said some joke that I didn't mean to
tell that I knew would get me [__]
canceled to say film that if they aired
it and in the middle of my set I just
looked at the camera and I was like do
not put that on TV like I don't know
where else to say I just don't do that
please rush you'll be over before it
started
and and then kept going with my set so
it helps in a lot of ways for that so
when that when the shows not going well
and this this ties into Earl Anderson's
question he asks advice for winning back
a room so how when it's not going well
will you judo the audience back to being
on your side well I think I kind of have
a privilege I'm acting from I'm speaking
from privilege right now because I mean
look at me
it's not I'm not like the I don't walk
on stage and people go now [__] her you
know I mean I have like a really
friendly face hmm and a really friendly
like look and then so all I really have
to do is like smile and ask somebody if
they're dating you know what I mean it's
like it's not that hard for me to win a
room back just because of how I look and
and so I'm not even like the right
person necessarily ask that have I ever
said anything that went so far that it
walked people yes I definitely like I
was at Zanies in Chicago and I heard
somebody flip the [__] out at the end of
my show
and it was like I was like I've been
saying horrible [__] this whole time you
know what I mean and but for some reason
this one joke just left this person they
were like well forget best you know and
and I if anything I was just proud of
that I was like oh cool there's a person
that I I wasn't able to win back like
what a nice challenge I think it's like
it's a fun thing to try to learn how to
do but you kind of have to be aware of
what you look like how how much of an
uphill battle that's going to be and who
are you when you are trying to get a job
you know it's sort of you have to go
into that energy yeah and it sounds like
you you go back to them like to being in
the present moment so if it's not going
well you almost like you said I smile
and I will engage the audience in a like
a kind way with a smile it's almost like
you have to take a step back be like
okay I'm plotting through my material
bombing let me take a step back and just
be in the moment with this audience
engage them in a genuine way and that
will almost kind of break the tension
yeah I mean even if they don't like me
and I don't like them if I'm smiling
looking them in the eyes and
acknowledging that fact then that alone
can break the tension I think yes like
if I'm just looking at someone in the
front row and he's going hey yeah like
how how are you you seem to hate me
that's so great yeah acknowledging their
body language anything that you are
picking up on in a moment I think help
yeah I just did I just posted on our
YouTube like a review of Chris D'Elia
special and just his use of smiling and
how like he would use a smile as like
tags to his jokes or almost they would
punctuate his jokes it's like he was
really good at remembering to smile and
that really course is the audience to
like get on board and smear your smile
and they're already halfway to laughing
if they're smiling so super powerful
yes super-powerful yeah yeah I agree
Brandon Cressy asks worst city to do
comedy in I don't think I've done comedy
in enough cities to really answer that
question and also why why it does that
matter I don't know yeah just pop up
yeah
Brandon she's trying to get booked in
cities right now we're not going to or
something he's like say Toledo sake yeah
actually I have nothing against Toledo I
don't know booking I mean the one place
that I had I would say kind of like a
shitty time but it wasn't it wasn't the
town it was just like the circumstances
it was like two days after my dog I had
to put my dog down and then I had to go
open for Pablo Francisco in Appleton
Wisconsin and I was like this is work I
was just like I can't do this this is
awful I remember I had a panic attack on
stage and then I got what if I had a
seizure I was like if I had a seizure
right now they would all think it was an
act out and I would be dead who were
they realized hmm but this wasn't a bit
and I had that I had that realization
and I couldn't say it out loud because I
was in the middle of a panic attack
about it so I just had to like get
through my set thinking I'm not having a
seizure I'm not having a seizure I was
just like having this like crazy
traumatic like [__] moment up there
and I just had to like finish my set and
it was it was so bad like it was so
awful it was like if you were it's like
if you were John Wayne Gacy and you were
in your clown costume realizing you were
about to get caught like that was what I
felt like it was just leaking why right
now is this at like what was happening
in the world was so not aligned with
what was happening in my head
and in my body that I was that it was
like comically awful how did you get
through it you just were like focusing
on one bit at a time type deal
I just did my [__] set I so nailed it
in mm-hmm
yeah like just get your [__] set and
go home and just lock yourself in that
hotel room and order a pizza well that's
uh that's that's good advice for anyone
just think about pizza if you're having
a panic attack on stage yeah oh yeah
don't worry Brandon asked about worse
City but then he also called me michael
cera so he's not a credible he's not a
credible source brian is like yeah I've
heard it before I actually took I
actually took a photo with someone after
a show because I thought I was Michael
Cera and I just played along with it
great that's a great move just go should
open up a cameo what happened that's a
great idea it's just that get some of
this quarantine coin yeah exactly
get the bag back Oh Matta Matt Taylor
says love rosebud she was my favorite on
inside jokes oh great yeah that's so
sweet
let me see we have a few more here yeah
Dylan O'Neill who was actually all the
way from Ireland actually this one's
coming from but he said first off wanted
to say I loved you on inside jokes
rosebud and I wondered as a comedian how
do you break down the most vulnerable
parts of your life and make them
humorous on stage I'm trying to do it
with gambling but haven't been able to
break through yet um I think a certain I
think I already went into this a little
bit but I can add one more thing to it
that you know a lot of times you'll
you'll feel uncomfortable about the bit
but that doesn't necessarily mean it's
not funny
you might just be uncomfortable
revealing yourself on stage and so what
I would say is if you think something's
funny keep telling the joke until you're
so comfortable telling it that you don't
care if it bombs or not and at that
point once you're comfortable saying it
then I think the funny comes through but
it takes some practice to just be able
to be like alright you know these people
are gonna find us out about me but how
do we know that those people that are
listening to you don't have [__] up
[__] that they're trying to hide you
know cuz a lot of times people won't
laugh at stuff not because of what
you're saying not because what you're
saying isn't funny but because they're
uncomfortable laughing at that part of
themselves so it's I would just say keep
you know be on your own side be your own
advocate keep telling a joke until you
know run about your friends your comic
friends can help a lot with this [__]
because they can see what's funny about
something before you can sometimes and
then you can build off of like the
things that they've helped you with I
had to run this to jokes about my sister
by so many people I had to get tags from
people I needed I needed help with that
bit man um and it's not done yet but I
think if you just keep working at it it
it does end up you'll get there is what
I'm saying
if you know what your thing is if you
know what your dark where your skeletons
are and you're willing to just go there
then great that's like most people don't
even know that they don't even know what
part of themselves is like shameful you
know great
point yeah knowing where the skeletons
are and then being willing to talk about
them yeah that's great yeah and it is
like yours it starts off with you
knowing there's something funny there
you just haven't found it yet
but if you believe there's something
there it seems like just it's a matter
of time if you're willing to put in the
work to find it that you'll eventually
find it with those steps you just said
so right it's super helpful yeah and I
think that's what Leo leo was saying
with like pretty much so you naturally
think of a shock value joke or awful
thing that's immediately funny to you
and then you later figure out a better
way to build it up and soften the punch
with like taking it to people that you
trust yeah
great good um good break down there Leo
yeah so just look we have like two more
here
if that's okay with you are you good
right now yeah yeah great Trent Babb
asks what's the difference between act
outs and overselling it I would say you
know I I think it's the only difference
is like the way that you judge it I
don't I don't think it's like you could
watch somebody who's great at act out
and well like sometimes you'll see and
act out in a place where it doesn't need
to be you know you'll see a comic kind
of doing with their body what they could
where they could just like tell a joke
like the joke is there and the joke is
strong enough and that you see them
doing like a phone call or like a you
know I mean and so I guess there's
something about overselling it that just
feels inorganic yeah but yeah I guess
that would be that would be the
difference when I'm when I'm watching it
but I I mean I don't know you could take
a boomerang of me on stage and it looks
like a photograph so I
I asked that I think it also I think it
comes down to authenticity again like
you're saying you know like if yes if
it's true to you and your comedy style
then it won't seem like you're
overselling it but if it looks like
you're trying to do something for the
sake of you like replicating some other
version of a comedian you saw then it
will come off as oversell if it looks
like you are trying to get into act outs
you know I mean then then you're
overselling if it looks like you just
found out oh I think I need more act out
in my comedy right it's like what you
know like somebody came up to me and
they were like you should do more act
out and I was like why I don't I don't
need to I mean I can move more onstage
but I don't need to do act out so it's
not like a thing that it would look like
someone having a breakdown just who I am
oh and Carly was sympathizing with your
panic attacks on stage she says she does
it all the time where she thinks what
would happen if I got sick on stage no
one would help me so then I start
panicking
yikes yeah yeah the weird thing but it's
just coming back just trying to be as
present as possible I guess helps or
like you did with that set muscle in
three oh yeah I mean it was also
connected cuz my dog had a seizure right
and I'd never seen like somebody have a
seizure before but it was like that was
from like alcohol [__] so like I hadn't
seen a seizure come on all of a sudden
and I just thought maybe there's
something in my apartment and maybe I
have it too and I just like I started
like it was nuts but yeah crazy you just
go through it you just go just breathe
just breathe
remember to breathe yeah and this is a
business question I'm Reax
is a manager necessary and if so when a
manager is only necessary
once you're starting to be approached by
managers hmm
before that you don't have enough going
on for a manager to be able to help you
anyway and I think getting a manager too
soon is you're just giving money away
for no reason because they're not going
to they're really just going to be like
answering emails for you and you might
feel important or something but you'll
realize like the managers that come in
oh no we lost her sound maybe she'll be
back with her other earbuds and we'll
wrap this up good questions though kids
great questions everyone will go ahead
and lay in this plane here and just like
another question just because we've been
going for a nice minute now but a lot of
great questions everyone it's just in
memento and just to piggyback off what
she was saying is I interviewed Tamara
Goins on the podcast that she's the head
of comedy innovative artists and she was
a manager agent and she said don't you
don't need a manager until you have
something worth managing so keep that in
mind with your career as well that just
wait till you have something worth
managing before you need a manager and
it was interesting to hear
Rosebud's say earlier that when she
talked to a manager at jfl she already
knew what she wanted and she already had
a vision for what she was wanting to
accomplish in comedy so until you know
those answers so there's no reason to
get like a manager agent or someone to
make you feel important like she said
cool are you can you hear me
oh yeah thanks for everyone that tuned
in there these are all great questions
and you guys are all for tuning in be
sure to share this as well sure this was
other comics that we out share and trich
says it's great seeing her upset about
her headphones it is authentic you're
right I think that's yeah it was good
she's about to put in some earbuds and
we're gonna wrap this up here hey sorry
about that no you're great we'll go
ahead and lay in this plane because
we're we're at about what about an hour
here so we got good advice and I was
just talking to them about I had
interviewed the head of comedy of
innovative artists and she's a manager
and agent as well and her thing was like
you don't need a manager to you have
something worth managing so there's you
know it's like one one piece of just
focus on getting funny and all your
opportunities will come from that so you
and your you're quick yeah success in
terms of just six years in and all
you've been able to do is because you're
authentic and you're funny and I think
comedy needs more comedians like you and
I'm I'm thrilled for your success
because you're showing not only the
comics that it's possible but it's also
like this is how it can be done in an
authentic way which i think is why so
many people really like I've like I've
done several of these but when I posted
you were gonna be on here so many people
were just like yes she's one of my
favorites I love they were able to name
specific things about like your bits or
things I heard you do and I think that
often this authenticity other things of
that that's what makes you so memorable
I think is your authenticity so yeah
thank you
thank you so much that means a lot to me
well I really appreciate you doing this
and you know this is like a comedy
education show so before we get out of
here is
any other favorite advice you've gotten
or any wisdom you could bestow upon the
hot breath averse I would just say if
you know if you're just getting into
comedy you know the most important thing
and I hated hearing this was just get
funny and that's I know it's like it's
been said so many [__] times and you
and you especially when you're like two
years in you want like a cheat sheet
I've had comics come up to me and go
what did you do how did you get where
you are and I'm like I just wrote jokes
and everything kind of took care of
itself
and I you know there is like it's it's a
thing that you can study like you can
learn comedy you don't have to be born
funny I don't think I was born funny I I
think I kind of it was like a
combination like like there were things
that I did that were funny but I didn't
realize it and I'm kind of trying to get
a little bit more into that like I'm
trying to get a little bit more into
like the silly side of me and I'm doing
it a lot and with my podcast with Andy
find your Beach and it will plug there
but we'll put it on yeah yeah but you
can learn to get funny you just have to
study comedy the way that you know you
have to learn comedy and and try to
approach it the same way that you would
approach learning piano you know yep
yeah yep that's that gold advice yeah I
mean that's the whole goal with hot
breath and the podcasts and the comedy
Network and all the content we create
here is helping comics giving them
access to comedians like you and the
lessons you've learned the hard way but
it is it comes down to you've got to be
willing to put in the work at the end of
the day there's no short oh I want to
say one more yeah I want to say one more
thing
so if you if you don't have a therapist
and you can afford it get a therapist
because you will learn about yourself
you know you learn deeper parts of
yourself and without that knowledge
you're not going to be able to write
from a place of depth so I think getting
a therapist or like even if you don't
have one if you can't afford one get a
journal start like asking yourself
questions about [__] you know like any
kind of question worth like why do I
fear this thing right why do I fear
losing my career right if your answer to
that question that that question holds a
lot right if your answer to that
question is I don't know you have a
shitload to learn about yourself if you
can't answer why am i afraid of being
alone in a way that's like you have a
definitive answer you have a lot to
learn about yourself so like there's so
many things about us that that we have
to discover to get funny and to get and
to get real with our audience and I
think we kind of have to excavate [__]
from ourselves that other people aren't
really willing to to excavate you know
connage have to be honest with
themselves in a way that other people
don't want to be so um that's the other
that's the other party advice that I
give and if you don't know those answers
yet and you can't afford therapy how do
you excavate that is it just repetition
of asking yourself over and over again
well it's like why am i okay I'll give
you an example of like so let's say
alright if I was going to answer that
question why am i afraid of being alone
um because I I don't want to die alone
okay why why don't you want to die alone
because if i dial
it'll be sad and it's like okay for who
for me okay but you'll be dead so what
is it really you know what I mean like
and the truth of the matter is like why
am I afraid of being alone because I'm
because I don't want to feel all of my
feelings
because I see it because I'm still
judging sadness as something as
something bad is happening right but
that's not necessarily true if you're
sad it doesn't mean something bad is
happening it means that you there's I
could just keep going with this but
don't get it like yeah just sell through
it ask yourself the questions ask
yourself what's at stake and really
answer it like from a place of real
vulnerability and just see what you find
out about yourself you know I love that
that's some of my favorite advice we've
interviewed over 200 comics but that's
that's so my favorite advice right there
that self-reflection and like self
excavation I I really love that thanks
for sharing that thanks for being
willing to share that also yeah well
what else is seven years at therapy
going to do well worth the price so you
if you had started to plug earlier but
please please plug everything you have
going on please I am a huge fan yeah so
I I have a podcast called devil's
advocate on all things potty that comes
out every Tuesday I've been doing them
alone lately which I wasn't the plan
originally but I I'm kind of loving it
um I also have a podcast called find
your Beach with my fiance Andy and we we
wake every morning with podcasts at
every single day of the quarantine um
that one is very silly and and stupid
and gross and fun and what else we also
have going on
I I'm doing a segment for the weekly
which is Australia's daily show I'll be
doing some correspondent work on that
and then beside that I'm that's it I'm
heading back to New York next week and I
was gonna go right into the belly of the
beast
what yep what yeah I needed to get on a
plane I can't stay here anymore this is
purgatory and I want them to let me in
to help you so that is that's how I'm
done Wow
I blame Andi for that the quarantine
with the fiance has driven you to ground
zero he wanted to stay and I was like
absolutely not we thought I'd go back to
New York and he's going with you he's
going to also yeah that is love that
he's willing at yo all right well this
may be it so I'm glad we got rosebud
zero-hour here that's great yeah and all
your social media anything they could
follow you is that all rosebud I believe
yeah it's rosebud Baker on Instagram
tik-tok Twitter all that jazz Facebook
blah blah blah I'm I'm same on all of
them this has been so great branding
kids yes I keep it all the same there's
some some people are Gumby on Twitter
and then they're Jedi 27 on Instagram
yeah keep it all the same yeah beautiful
alright well that's it hot breath averse
go forth support rosebud follow her
listened to all of her podcasts and we
will see you back here with another
comedians on skype talking comedy yeah
everyone's saying great thanks rosebud
everyone's saying great job everyone
loved it alright y'all thank you of
course thanks for putting so much great
comedy out there for us to enjoy
absolutely that's so sweet
I really this was really fun oh good
yeah we'll have to get um let's see what
other comics we can get on here you
think of any other comics that may enjoy
doing this I mean Andy might like doing
it if you want to have Andy on it could
be so funny if you were like yeah yeah
we'll uh we'll schedule one to do with
Andy yeah I've a been a fan of Andy
since he did a modern comedian did you
ever see that modern comedian he did
where it was him preparing for a conan
set you never even saw your your
fiance's content yeah this was several
years ago Scott Moran who's like a
director in comedy now he did this web
series about comedians and his was his
with Andy was him preparing for his
first conan set so yeah but I've been
tipped to Andy for a minute so yeah
we'll definitely connect after this and
get Andy on here soon all right hot
bread verse yeah have a good day we love
you all right hey hot brother and
sister-in if you love comedy as much as
we do here at hot breath click the
subscribe button to join the hot breath
averse and then watch more videos to get
even more comedy tips